ocho años del caso Ayotzinapa el 26 de
septiembre de 2014 43 estudiantes de la
normal desaparecieron la comisión de la
verdad determinó el pasado 17 de agosto
que de hecho se trató de un crimen de
estado en el que participaron militares
hasta el momento se han dictado órdenes
de detención contra más de 80
sospechosos entre ellos militares
policías y miembros de carteles el
viernes 19 de agosto el ex fiscal
general del país Jesús Murillo fue
arrestado tras ser acusado de
desaparición forzada no denunciar
tortura y Mala conducta oficial para
conducir a las pesquisas de los
responsables los familiares siguen
exigiendo justicia por parte del Estado
y claman por encontrar a los
desaparecidos es preocupante decir que
hasta el día de hoy no sabemos nada de
nuestros hijos y eso es que nos duele de
lo en lo más profundo de nuestro corazón
no saber a dónde está nuestros hijos y
es por eso que estamos aquí este dejando
familia en nuestros hogares dejando todo
nuestro trabajo por venir aquí por
manifestarnos qué queremos la verdad A
dónde está nuestros hijos no podemos
permitir más injusticias basta de
impunidad este viernes en el plantón
organizado en una base militar de México
hubo enfrentamientos con la policía los
manifestantes intentaron derribar las
vallas tratando de Acceder al campo
militar número uno de la capital
que nos Comenten y nos informan Por qué
no se han ejecutado las órdenes de
aprehensión contra los demás elementos
del ejército desde que asumió el
presidente Andrés Manuel López Obrador
ha asegurado que este crimen no quedará
impune